attention la suisse en six ans et marc
jolivet qui trouve la réponse c'est ça
allégis mais s'il faut envoyer des
forces armées terrestres au kosovo je
veut bien prêter ma voiture bien prêté
ma voiture
qui suis je je suis un qui suis-je
mais c'est sûr qu'il serait attribué au
nord
tout un arsenal dans son coin et se
verrait bien continuer les anglais mois
à moitié amnistié je ne sais pas encore
si c'est la partie qui nous la partie
auch est beaucoup trop facilement dans
les ports du bambou beaucoup plus facile
j'ai dû demander à ma grand-mère de
faire des économies
sinon au loup une mercedes et on emmène
au ritz de paris pour lui fêter son
centième anniversaire
bravo d'ailleurs l'émission sans vous
sans vous mettre tous dans le public et
qu'on mette en musique autour de ça
depuis qu'on sait que lionel jospin veut
faire vérifier tous les tunnels
mon avocat m'a conseillé de me planquer
christine deviers joncour
trouve à cet endroit malherbe
comment voulez vous que j'ai la clé de
la paix au kosovo on voit déjà pas me
donner celle du minibar rsa qui suivent
le mini bar qui suffisent
c'est pas un nom que je vais vous
demander parce que c'est plutôt une
devinette
le mari de céline dion ou eric céline
dion mais lui a séduit assez l'amour
pendant une heure et sans viagra
comment casser pour eux avec points dont
un avec la avec une piqûre ou non eh
bien écoutez je peux vous dire comment
c'était le week-end dernier en france
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche entre
2h et 3h qu'on a changé d'horaire je
sais très bien là on a perdu une heure
là perdu et puis c'est le cas
aujourd'hui c'est plus facile dans ce
sens là parce que dans la chevènement a
fait la gueule il devait se réduire il
tu vas dormir une heure en plus c'est
assez dégueulasse à une dernière c'est
grâce à moi la suisse est désormais plus
connu pour ses montgolfière que pour ses
cerfs-volants
qui suis-je non non non non pica pica
jeu mais porté plainte contre le parc
eurodisney parce que j'ai eu l'idée de
rétrécir mon public bien avant eux
ah ouais caresser son public bruel